In Spain, the death toll in the country from the coronavirus pandemic surpassed 1,000 Friday,...
...the country's health emergencies chief Fernando Simon said.
The number of registered cases in the country rose to 19,980 on Friday.
A passenger ship docked at the port of Genoa...
...is set to become a hospital Friday for people suffering from the coronavirus,...
...as Italy's death toll overtook that reported by China, where the virus first emerged.
In the US, Secretary of State Mike Pompeo announces a mutual agreement with Mexico...
...to restrict "non-essential travel" across the southern border,...
...in an effort "to limit the spread of the virus...
...and to ensure that the commerce that supports our economy continues to keep flowing."
President Emmanuel Macron said France is only at the beginning of the coronavirus crisis...
...and is in a race to curb the spread of the coronavirus.
The country has 10,995 confirmed cases as of Friday.
Finally from Japan, the Japanese welcome the Olympic flame in a scaled-down ceremony...
...due to coronavirus concerns.
Doubts are growing...
...over whether the Tokyo Games will go ahead on schedule with the coronavirus pandemic.